The Japanese are the biggest consumers of plastic in the world after the U.S.
Visit a Japanese supermarket and you'll find that just about all of the fresh produce,...
...vegetables, fruit, meat and fish, is wrapped in plastic.
At the register, employees place wrapped items into a plastic bag and then into another plastic bag.
Mio Takase is among a growing number of people who are battling Japan's addiction to plastic.
This is wrapped in three different kinds of plastic:...
...one is this, and then the second one is this plastic here, and the third one is this here.
It has quite strong skin so it doesn't really need this packaging.
Plastic is synonymous with hygiene, high-quality service and even luxury.
The government recently said it would ban free plastic bags by 2020.